all I want to do is listen to my crime
podcasts and watch my true crime shows a
scary story you are not as good as
Dateline watch let's dim the lights hi
I'm Hannah and I'm the world's okay it's
mom anything okay hi I'm Hannah and I'm
the world's OH case mom and if you're a
parent like me living in this day and
age technology is a big deal I feel like
I use screens all the time as a crutch
and as a babysitter for my kids
I got screens on screens on screens so I
want to try something for a whole week
I'm gonna cut the cord for my entire
family and hopefully it brings us closer
together
maybe it'll drive us insane but we'll
see what happens so wish me luck so the
rules in our house were no TV no
internet no use of phones and no
electronic games as far as me and Matt
when we're at work we're allowed to use
our computers we're allowed to keep our
phones on in case of emergency with the
kids we just weren't allowed to use
anything for any other purpose besides
strictly work so no browsing social
media no scrolling through BuzzFeed
articles to find out which type of cake
I am we couldn't even use our phones to
stream audio what we were driving oh and
one more thing obviously I need to use
my camera on my phone to make this video
so that's something that was also
happening they're up early and this is
when I let them watch a little TV but
we're not gonna do that so I'm gonna get
up and play oh they always wake up super
Restless I feel like that's just the
thing with young kids they wake up and
they're like where we going I want to
get dressed I'm hungry
they're always hungry so I had to get up
too right we're not watching TV today
don't Wyatt don't turn it on doing it
don't do it
don't be a bad enjoyment we're just
gonna play today no we're not gonna play
video games today remember now I thought
that that morning was the worst of it
but I didn't realize just how much we
would have to detox throughout the day
Jackson put it away put it away okay I'm
gonna count three why I know no one your
subject no no so I can't check my work
email I'm kind of dying it's only been
like half a day and I'm kind of
struggling I know I checked my work
email on the weekends and I know you
shouldn't and I know that you're
supposed to just turn off when you go
home but I am super high-strung and a
little bit obsessive I think a lot of
that stems from being a working parent I
always worry that things are falling
between the cracks because I'm dividing
my time I want to call my mom and we
don't have a landline
the first casualty of this week was a
plan that I had made to see my mom the
first day I was gonna see her this
weekend and so now I don't know what to
do
there was no way for me to get ahold of
her to coordinate meeting her so I
didn't even know if it was worth driving
over because I could just show up and
she wouldn't be home sorry mom she
understands however one thing that
didn't suffer this week in our house was
the music we're gonna say bye to Google
by doodle
any last words we're gonna miss ya
hey cuz we're I'm plugging her goodbye
Google we are luckily very hipster
parents we have an old record player
so we whipped that out this week and
just played a bunch of records and it's
always really fun the kids get excited
about that too halfway through the first
day I was already so bored I think we
were all so bored so what we ended up
doing for a good few hours was just
cleaning I share a bathroom with three
boys oh man this is just look at that
toilet this is amazing we even clean the
bathtub I think the kids were so mad but
I was really pleased at the end so today
the kids are getting a little restless
so we're gonna get out of the house
again we're gonna go to a flea market I
love doing flea market days because
there's so much to see and so much to do
and the kids get a lot of you know
walking and exercise and they have a
really fun time just checking out all
the cool stuff that they have to offer
one thing I did not think of is at the
flea market like the whole point of
going is I try to get good deals on
stuff the way I do that is by googling
what it is and seeing how much it costs
on other websites so there are these
super cute leather boots they're fifty
dollars they fit me perfectly they're so
dang cute but I don't know if I'm
getting a good deal I don't know what to
do
I got a few crystals cuz I'm pretty
savvy with what's a good deal on
crystals I got a Lucky Penny
he found a Lucky Penny and I just I
didn't get the boots I I don't want to
risk it you know when you're a family of
four on a budget you can't go spending
50 bucks and something it's not a good
deal so we'll see two hundred and fifty
dollars I could have gotten those boots
for 50 bucks then they're two hundred
and fifty dollar boots oh my gosh that
is so
I'm so mad right now Monday was a
holiday so we just sucked it up
I packed everyone in the car and we
drove to my parents house in hopes of
finding my sister Stella we are headed
to the park to exert some energy because
we need to get outside desperately what
better way to distract ourselves from no
technology than by going to the park go
and this part doesn't even have a
service did you use my phone he's sleepy
and the park was really nice honestly I
really enjoyed the day that we go there
and just spend the day and have a blast
it was nice to be able to see my sister
overall Monday was a great day and I
didn't even Instagram about it so
technically it never happened so Tuesday
first day at work
with no technology and right off the bat
I knew this was gonna be a rough week my
round-trip commute is around three hours
so that's my time that I really utilize
podcasts but without using my phone and
plugging it into my car I really had
nothing to listen to I'm not gonna
listen to the radio because let's be
real the radio doesn't even play music
anymore so my solution remember these
I love born horns if you're watching
this my birthday is in July and I would
really love a private concert if you're
available and I also really love Kate
Bush for anyone who is as old as I am so
I got those two CDs and I felt like I
was pretty set for the week I know I was
so excited to find two CDs and purchase
them for my car but uh of those two CDs
they're only about seven songs that I
like so for the past week I've just been
listening to those seven songs over and
over and over so now I've resorted to
driving to work in silence Jackson
had a little bit of a hard time letting
go of his technology are you guilty you
surrender how was tonight with no TV are
you okay that I took away your game I
love you
what they didn't even dawn on me that I
didn't realize until that night you know
what else I realized we never text we
can't text during the day did you even
notice yeah I didn't even notice I
wasn't texting I have no one to text
people aren't nice to me about my kids
there's no one for me to text
when Jackson gets a phone all of it had
someone to text now Wednesday for me was
a really busy day at work but it was a
different kind of busy I was actually in
an all day long workshop from 9:00 a.m.
to 6:00 p.m. by Wednesday I was flat out
struggling which I didn't think was
gonna be the case I thought it'd be the
kids having a hard time and me doing
okay but the kids seem to be doing just
fine and in fact they surprised me
Jackson all on his own got out a book
and just started reading while I cook
how cool is that Jackson you're doing
awesome
what activity do you want to do stamps
okay let's do it
so Thursday was Wyatt's turn to kind of
have a hard time and melt down what do
you want
Wyatt Google's not on right now whenever
I said no he just he couldn't take it
anymore
at one point he actually said to me stop
taking your stuff away I felt his pain
he was very inconsolable and he was very
upset and I wholeheartedly understood
where he was coming from it's tough I
know so by Friday we were all just
really sick of each other and and really
sick of this experiment and that's when
literally hit the fan I am in the
bathroom trying to fix my hair I leave Y
it out there unattended for all of five
minutes and he rushes in here presenting
me with a giant in his diaper that he's
ripped off of his butt and this is why I
need cartoons at this point I will take
Caillou I'll take anything I need him to
watch something for five minutes that I
can do my hair I there's no one to blame
but me but the silver lining was
something really special that common you
guys will never believe what I just
found boom you probably don't even know
what this is but it is a CD holder for
all my burned CDs and I am so excited I
feel like I just struck gold I hit the
jackpot here
okay I don't have too much to work with
but I am really curious to try this uh
camped CD out it doesn't even look too
scratched so maybe I'll give it a couple
okay right off the bat it's Clay Aiken
maybe this is why to navigate fresh what
did I learn from this week a whole lot
first and foremost I learned that well
we're not the worst at utilizing
technology and social media and screen
time there's a lot that we can cut out
of our daily routine - I learned that I
need to step back from work a little
more as a working mom I know that I feel
two steps behind everybody else I have
so much that I'm responsible for and so
much that I'm keeping track of that I'm
always utilizing my time away from work
to catch up on anything I missed but I
need to remind myself that that time
away from work is my time and that time
is important it's important to just take
the time away and third while there is a
lot of technology that's a little
excessive I think that there is a
healthy balance and there's a lot of
technology that we use that enriches our
lives
for example calling my mom in the
morning and calling a friend who lives
out of state it keeps you connected to
the people who don't see on a daily
basis and if you're not overdoing it I
think it's just super useful and
important to maintain and fourth I
learned that I was a weird kid with
horrible taste in music and I'm kind of
proud of it so that's all I got for
today I'm Hannah and I have to know have
you tried something like this have you
reduced your screen time or even for
your whole family let me know in the
comments tell me how it went or you can
text me this is a real number and I do
read every single message
I don't always respond to them all
because I get a lot but I love to hear
what you guys have to say now if you'll
please excuse me I only have about 50
hours of podcasts to catch up on on my
ride home so I will see you guys later
till next time I don't need these
anymore
[Music]